I live in in Berkeley and I've been
living there for thirty years and I know
all the streets of how to get to my home
and my work but I still use Google Maps
because at any point in time you don't
know the amount of traffic between where
you are and when you want to go and
which one of the many routes available
to you has an accident or slow down or
too many other people are going on the
value of exterior mapping is I think
well I know pretty well understood by
the by the public interiors you can
argue less about people getting lost and
traffic and stuff like that but imagine
a package delivery like Amazon is going
to deliver our packages through drones
all the way to the exterior of our
building but then you wanted the last
mile of delivering those same things
into different offices or apartments
inside the building and that would also
require mapping so the idea is to make
an interior mapping be seamlessly
integrated with the exterior mapping so
that you can have true end-to-end
connectivity between two different
points all of us through the through
this amazing device will carry with
ourselves cell phones are continuously
collecting signals and images and data
about our surrounding whether or not we
know it and whether or not we like it
we're doing that unconsciously all the
time through crowdsourcing so if you get
the aggregate of all the people who are
going into all these indoor spaces you
have the potential to map every every
indoor space the the the typical cell
phone has over 40 sensors accelerometers
gyroscopes barometers thermometers Wi-Fi
signal Bluetooth all kinds of RF RF
signal gathering capability and so I had
to say but a lot of it are being tracked
because to use a lot of the applications
on your phone you're allowed the company
that sold you the phone to to collect
that information and that's almost
synonymous with mappings and those could
be used in order to map the
Interiors the very same people whose
whose crowdsource data you use to map
you can use that same information to
locate people when there is an emergency
either an earthquake fire or anything
like that the first responders will have
a lot easier time knowing where people
are and knowing how to rescue people
that and just having more information
it's always useful the other positive
thing in terms of knowing where you are
is that and how many people are aware
and knowing the maps is that is this
idea of smart buildings you can control
the many many sensors and actuators that
are inside the building to your liking
so suppose that I like the temperature
in my office to be no no warmer than 64
just just because there's a map and
because then they know where I am when
I'm not in my office it's not gonna be
any cold HVAC air being pumped into it
that saves energy and when I'm a day
that I'm not working in my office but
working you know in the conference room
across the hall from my office
the same temperature preferences can be
applied to that room localizing people
enables them to be more comfortable and
more in tune with the environment that
that they're in and it could result in
potential energy savings inside
buildings if that information is readily
available
[Music]